fanny la chenille c'est une histoire de
mado mais illustré par hoarau
il y avait une fois un jardin devenu
sauvage dans ce jardin
poucet parmi tant d'autres un arbuste
couvert de feuilles et de fleurs
bien à l'abri sous l'une de ses feuilles
étaient cachées un petit fin
un beau matin du petit oeuf n'acquittent
une chenille
comme elle n'avait ni parents ni amis
elle choisit d'elle même le prénom de
fanny
fanni était heureuse de s'éveiller à la
vie est très vite la fin la saillie
ainsi chaque jour elle dévorait
quantité de feuilles vert d étendre
un devenait si grâce si lourde qu'elle
en était désespérée
bientôt les tiges ne porteront plus et
malgré les ventouses de mes patins je
tomberai jeu dégringolerait
souvent ses yeux se lever vers l'azur
elle regardait avec envie tous ces
insectes pour vis d'elle
jamais je n'avais réussi à échanger un
seul mot avec la moindre coccinelle la
moindre libellule le moindre papillon
tous et fleurette à peine les plantes
autour d'elle pour ensuite s'envoler de
plus belle
des fleurs c'était fans et de nouvelles
s'était épanouie
20 jours ou un insecte se posa et sata
dans quelque peu
fanny sacoche en hâte et se présente à
l'insecte se présenta aussi
je suis si belle la bei je passe de
fleur en fleur mutine ans çà et là
comme je t'admire lui dit fanny tuer si
légère tu peux aller venir à tongres et
alors que moi je suis prisonnière de ce
jardin qui plus est je n'ai pas d'amis
tout en l'écoutant si belle ne sais
c'est de travailler
c'est en prenant son envol qu'elle lui
cria comment tu ne connais pas ta
destinée
aujourd'hui je suis pressé
la prochaine fois je te dirai ce qu'il
en est
ces paroles se perdirent dans le vent
fanny resta seul encore plus triste
qu'avant
le soir même de cette rencontre la
chenille d'ordinaire si souples se
sentit devenir raid coincé engourdi elle
se faufila entre les branches puis se
figea
un manteau de sommeil
l'enveloppa alors est elle sombra dans
le noir
les plants étaient maintenant plus
couverte de fleurs que jamais cybèle
revint maintes fois puisé du nectar
cueillir du pollen mais le s'inquiéta
nullement de l'absence de famille
et puis par un matin clair un gracieux
papillons aux ailes fraîchement tisser
se pose à tout prêt de la bei
ensemble elles s'envolaient vers l'azur